how much water would you need to
extinguish the Sun how would we deliver
such an enormous amount of water anyway
and would all that water even make it to
the star wouldn't it evaporate before
reaching the Suns burning flares
whatever your plan is be careful because
trying to put out the Sun would only
make it hotter this is what is and
here's what would happen if we
extinguished the Sun before we dive into
how things would go terribly wrong let's
talk about where we could hypothetically
find all that water I've got some ideas
how about the universe's largest ice
cube a gigantic space fire hose or an
entire Waterworld
tossed into the Sun okay fine let's be a
little more realistic
no giant ice cube will be passing our
solar system anytime soon that leaves us
with one possible scenario we'd have to
sacrifice every single drop of water we
have here on earth we would drain our
oceans and deplete all the fresh water
too then we build a very large fire hose
and blast it at light speed towards the
Sun's core and then wait did I say that
was just one option I forgot about the
possibility of using a water world
leaving the earth with no Sun and no
water seems a bit unreasonable and we
could avoid that ocean draining scenario
if we found a way to throw an exoplanet
into the Sun but not just any exoplanet
we be aiming for a real-life Waterworld
and we just happen to know where to find
it some 40 light-years from Earth
there's a planet primarily made of water
with an atmosphere of steam scientists
named it GJ 121 for B but we'll call it
the water world this planet is 2.7 times
bigger than the earth in diameter and it
weighs 7 times more than our planet and
it has much less rock and a lot more
water than the earth does there would
probably be enough water on the water
world to put out the Sun forever but it
wouldn't happen the way you might expect
it to if we were able to crash that
water world into the Sun the first
problem would be the water freezing in
space same thing would happen if we
could pull out a gigantic firehose with
all of the Earth's water and aim it at
our star the ice would continue shooting
towards the Sun but it would face mass
evaporation as soon as it hit the stars
atmosphere is a water vapor would then
break down to its basic ingredients
oxygen and hydrogen and that's when
something interesting would happen the
Sun may seem like a huge fireball but
it's not exactly on fire inside its
blazing core the pressure is 340 billion
times more than it is on Earth's surface
this immense pressure fuses hydrogen
atoms together making helium and giving
off energy in the process since hydrogen
acts like a fuel for our Sun pouring
water on it would be like throwing
gasoline on a fire you'd see the Sun
turn bluish white as it grew six times
bigger it would create an extreme heat
wave across our planet but at least we
wouldn't be engulfed by the expanding
Sun although there could be other
consequences we wouldn't be able to put
out the Sun with its own fuel but if we
fired enough water at it at the
feet of lay it could break up the Sun
the pressure inside it would drop the
hydrogen couldn't fuse together into
helium and that would shut the Sun down
but with no Sun to give us warmth and
light the earth would turn into a frozen
world after just one year earth's
temperature would drop below minus 73
degrees most of the plants and animals
would be dead long before that and what
about us humans well in the deepest
parts of the oceans geothermal vents
could have kept us warm and supplied us
with energy but we just poured all of
Earth's water into the Sun dooming
ourselves to freeze lucky for us the
only thing in the universe that can do
any substantial harm to the Sun is the
Sun itself and that would take billions
of years to happen but that's a story
for another what is
[Music]